hey guys it's me Megan Kelly and I'm
here on my set we just shot a really
interesting interview Megan Kelly is
back at work less than a year after
leaving NBC we're just gonna think about
that for a little while wrap that around
me like a warm blanket after officially
saying goodbye to the network in January
it looks like the journalist might be
turning her Instagram account into a new
reporting platform so I do think that
there's there's an importance right now
of women leading by example and just
being their best selves and to extent I
can do that I love him on Friday the 48
year old posted her first video a clip
referencing ABC staff or amy robach who
was caught saying the network squashed a
story about Jeffrey Epstein the employee
and then moved on to CBS got fired this
week because they suspected she leaked
this thing to this project
Veritas which is the one that put it out
there well we just sat down with her we
got the full story this marks the first
independent interview Megan has
conducted since leaving NBC she first
signed the multimillion-dollar deal with
the network in 2017 after leaving Fox
News I'm so excited so excited I'm also
a little nervous mid-year Kelly kicked
off megyn kelly today but after a series
of controversial interviews public feuds
and an on-air blackface comment
truly you do get in trouble if you are a
white person who puts on black Halloween
or a black person who puts on white face
for Halloween
like back when I was a kid that was okay
as long as you were dressing there's
like a character the show was canceled
it's generally unpleasant to be the
subject of the story as opposed to the
one covering it in October Meghan
returned to TV for an interview on Fox
News's Tucker Carlson tonight where she
opened up about spending more time with
her three kids I'm mothering my own kids
there's no substitute for that you know
I lost my dad when I was 15 years old
and so I I know
I know on an inherent basis you don't
get a do-over right it's true so I'm I'm
there and I'm enjoying it and I get back
on that horse soon because this has been
fun
so I'll probably get back out there but
right now I'm I'm still enjoying my my
day-to-day life for my family and
friends